according to the kremlin this is the
last group of exhausted and deflated
ukrainian troops walking out of the azov
style steel works after more than 80
days inside the bombarded facility
russia now claims all 2400 ukrainian
troops inside have surrendered
earlier friday the leader of the azov
battalion admitted the fight for
azerstal was over russia says he was
taken away in an armored car they say to
prevent locals from attacking him
russia's invasion was predicated on the
far right routes of the azov battalion
so his capture would be a key propaganda
victory for the kremlin
in turkey the wives of some of the other
ukrainian soldiers appealed for help
fearing what will happen to them my
husband
is
on the way from one hell to another hell
from other steel plant to as a prison
change the heart and converts the hearts
with horrors like this the vatican's
foreign secretary visited the site of
mass graves north of key friday
responding to calls for pope francis to
travel to ukraine or to help with peace
talks he knows that there is a desire
for a visit and he is more than willing
to assist either himself personally or
through his
immediate
collaborators bombing continues across
the east including at this cultural
center in harkie region ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky says the
eastern donbass region is now completely
destroyed
russia's defense minister claims his
forces will soon have control over the
entire luhans part of the donbass
russian natural gas giant gazprom
announced friday it will now suspend all
sales to finland
for failing to pay its bills in rubles
just days after finland and sweden
formally applied to join nato redmond
shannon double news london